today we are gonna take a deep dive into
the issue of health care it's Labor Day
and one of the primary issues that is
intertwined with labor and working in
the United States is health care and
that's a problem I've been an advocate
for a long time of actually severing
that tie and this would be not only good
economically not only would it be good
for both workers and companies
economically to separate health care and
health insurance from jobs but it would
also be really good psychologically it
would be really good morally and
ethically quite frankly for people to be
able to pursue interests and jobs on the
basis of what they actually care about
and find rewarding rather than having to
make decisions about sticking it out in
a job that you hate because if you leave
the job you will lose health insurance
that could be still quite frankly
mediocre but better than the alternative
were cheaper than the alternative so
we're going to actually start today with
growing our understanding of where the
United States healthcare system is
ranked first of all because unless we
understand what we have now accurately
it's going to be hard to figure out the
direction that we should go in we will
then look at the impact of Obamacare
over the last several years something
that we've talked about before I will
also tell a story of my $829 a ten
minute specialists visit which still has
not been resolved by the way and then
we're going to get into debunking some
of the really bad arguments against
changing the healthcare system for
something more like every single other
rich Western developed country has
whether it's Canada or Germany or the UK
or many others that we've talked about
and then we will ultimately circle back
to how do we pay for this stuff and we
will talk to Gerald Friedman Jerry
Friedman from my undergraduate alma
mater the University of Massachusetts
about what would this actually cause
what would doing something like what
Bernie Sanders wants to do cost and what
you will notice when we go back to the
way that we have covered health care
over the years
that the themes and the substance have
stayed quite similar over the years but
the language used has become language
that understands that these ideas the
ideas of Bernie Sanders and other
leftists in the United States are on
health care have become significantly
mainstreamed where the language used to
be sort of apologetic we used to have to
understand that these were at least
considered radical far left ideas which
have been extraordinarily mainstreamed
particularly over the last three years
dating back really to Bernie Sanders
presidential candidacy Democratic
presidential candidacy in the 2016
Democratic primary so the substance is
much the same the analyses have not
drastically changed but there's
definitely a different tone in terms of
the political will and the
interpretation of a lot of this stuff so
let's get right into it a deep dive
today into the American health care
system the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the right likes to say national
healthcare systems are bad bad dad
Canada's terrible the UK is a disaster
it's all bad all in defense of this
immoral for-profit employer connected
health care system that we have in the
United States the DC think tank known as
the Commonwealth Fund did a study of the
health care systems of 11 wealthy
countries and it found may be a surprise
to some of you maybe not that the
American system is the worst by multiple
measures and this includes countries
like the UK Australia Canada Germany
Sweden the UK's national health services
was the best in many categories the five
categories evaluated were access to care
equality of access for people of
different incomes administrative
efficiency how well the care process
works and how good the health outcomes
are now it's not all a panacea for these
other countries right so like for
example the UK system was first overall
but was tenth in terms of health care
outcomes but the big consistency was
that the u.s. did terribly in every
single area access to care the u.s. was
a disaster for example 44% of low-income
people in the United States have trouble
accessing care compared to only 7% of
low-income people in the UK and notably
the report says that there's been some
improvement as a result of Obamacare but
this is more evidence that Obamacare is
no incredible wonderful appending of the
healthcare status quo it's a slight
improvement or it has slowed down the
worsening of some areas of the system
but it's no massive victory and in total
in overall performance the u.s. was dead
last the leaders were as I mentioned the
UK was first followed by Australia and
the Netherlands where the US turn up at
the top of the list of countries well in
terms of how much we spend we are
leading the way
and this relates to many many issues
this relates to the fact that we have a
system that seeks profit we've got a
total bureaucratic inefficiency due to
the medical billing and insurance system
that we have it's a total train wreck we
spend more than every other country on
the list and we have the worst overall
health care system how can anyone be
proud of that
you know right-wingers go on and on
about how America is number one I don't
think we're number one in this category
number 11 here this should be a point of
national pride right I mean to the
right-wing Patriots wouldn't it be nice
to be able to be really proud of how
well our health care system works
instead of like how many bombs we have
or something like that or does that
point of view make me a beta male I
don't know maybe it does that I think it
would be nice to be proud of our health
care system seems like you want poor
people to survive in this country there
are people to live longer and you see
perspective to have and no no country is
perfect some will point out that a
waiting times for some procedures are
longer in some of the countries on the
list
others might point out that costs might
be lower in other countries because
maybe nurses aren't paid well or
something like that there are always
problems but this study pretty nicely
sums up sort of like the net impact of
all aspects of the system and it's just
absolutely vile and disgusting and I
want to remind you I've said this before
there is something called HR 676 out
there HR 676 is a house proposal called
the expanded and improved Medicare for
all Act and it basically is single-payer
health care not in a literal sense what
it actually would do is take the
Medicare system we have which has done a
better job of holding costs not as high
lower might be a bit of a stretch but
from going as high it's a system that
works quite well in many ways the idea
would be to expand Medicare to everybody
this has been proposed a number of times
by House Democrats it basically never
has a shot at going anywhere but it is
there it is there and a lot of people
don't know about it and you can go to
who is my representative calm figure out
who does represent you in both the
Senate and the house start making calls
send faxes do whatever you want
I mean it seems like whenever we talk
about overhauling the healthcare system
you're going to have legislation that's
hundreds of pages long you know it's not
gonna be this simple but you're
effectively just making the age
requirement for Medicare zero and that's
a lot easier to do than to maybe pass
Obamacare or the American Health Care
Act all you're doing is going into
Medicare and this is a slight
oversimplification but changing the
minimum age at which you can get
Medicare it is a very interesting
proposal that is completely dead in the
water unfortunately but still HR 676
just talked about it call your
representatives about it let's talk
about Obamacare the Affordable Care Act
the last few days have seen a number of
very very apoplectic and out-of-control
headlines saying shocking Obama care
premiums up 22 percent 25 percent in
some cases and yes it is true that under
the Obamacare Affordable Care Act law
premiums for those plans will be up an
average of 22 percent next year there
are many consumers who will be down to
basically just one plan option through
the Obamacare exchanges and this is not
just opposition reporting the
administration itself has indeed
confirmed this but the misinformation
from so much of the alarmist
out-of-control reporting on this it's so
extensive that I want to dig into it
with you here at the top of the show
there are a whole bunch of different
pieces of information that are missing
from these reports people see a report
saying Obama care premiums up 22% number
one that ignores the subsidies on those
plans so while you will have an average
and this is based on the Silver level
plans
there's Bronze Silver Gold and Platinum
level plans that sort of establish
generally how much of one's health
insurance expenditures are covered by
insurance silver is the sort of
benchmark that is used 22 percent
increase in Obama care silver level
plans however most of that increase for
many obama care recipients is going to
be covered by subsidies so you
the headline and it makes for a really
great headline but it's not actually
telling us well how much more are the
individuals actually going to be paying
and of course this ignores altogether
that this has nothing to do at all with
individuals who have insurance through
their parent's insurance through their
employer insurance through their school
etc so really really interesting
headline Republicans are going
absolutely nuts about this we've heard
the term death spiral be used many many
times that Obamacare is just going to
basically self-destruct and implode but
it is super super important to
understand that this refers to a small
percentage of all the people in the
country and it also is not accounting
for the fact that many of these
increases are going to be covered
additionally let's not forget that we've
been seeing increases to premiums for a
very very long time and even without the
Affordable Care Act we would be seeing
increases to premiums would they be
higher or lower than with the Affordable
Care Act well it's hard to say remember
that even without the Affordable Care
Act even without an insurance mandate
uninsured people are still going to go
to the emergency room use it as primary
care and those who have insurance are
going to subsidize that that is a cost
part of which is eliminated by mandating
insurance the way we see through the
Affordable Care Act so there's a whole
bunch of stuff here guys which is not in
the headlines and it completely up ends
what the story here really is yeah we
don't really have a control here to see
how higher the premiums would have gone
out up without Obamacare now from 1999
to 2009 according to the Kaiser
Institute premiums for families nearly
doubled right in the Republican response
to all this is just to blow the whole
thing up to repeal it and kick 20
million people off their coverage no
doubt yeah and insurance subsidies cap
premiums at a percentage of families
income so many Americans won't end up
paying more and another issue here is
that this number also hides a lot of
local variation that people are unaware
of this is not a perfect system right I
don't think Pat thinks Obamacare is
perfect I don't think Rachel thinks
Obama
here is perfect I've been clear that
Obamacare is not perfect right it does
some good things the banning of
outrageous price increases or rejection
of coverage for pre-existing conditions
is a really good thing
allowing people under age 26 to stay on
their parent's insurance until age 26 is
a really good thing reducing or I guess
it's really the opposite growing the
pool of people who have insurance that
are paying something in is a good thing
and of course covering millions of
additional people is a really good thing
but the system at its core is so corrupt
and so immoral and so unethical that is
really the basic issue for me and the
Republicans who complain about the 22%
increase to silver level Obama care
plans not accounting for premiums and
the fact that most people aren't even on
these plans at all ignores that the
entire for-profit system we have is the
problem and if you turned it over to
Republicans they're not going to fix
that they're going to say we need more
competition we need to allow insurers to
say oh you have a pre-existing condition
you're out etc their views would only
make this problem worse and we know what
the most popular and cost-effective
health care programs are around the
world yet single payer that's what works
well in Britain and all over Europe all
over the world and instead we in America
have a long tradition of getting health
care coverage through our employers yeah
but really it's not the best way to go
and raychel think about all of the ways
in which the costs are obviously going
to be high you have middlemen earning
profits in ours in our health care
system all over the place you have
bureaucracy and complexity you have the
entire medical billing apparatus in many
cases preventive medicine is ignored
which we know over the long term
increases costs you're paying for the
uninsured
anyway anyway we have this current
situation of the aging baby boomer
population combined with an obesity
crisis that we can't possibly separate
from the factory food epidemic and
sedentary lifestyles of course it's
going to be expensive yeah it's really
difficult also for the families who make
too much to qualify for subsidies
subsidies they will find themselves in a
pinch and I'm equally worried for
people with chronic illnesses that have
to switch plans that may have been
getting a good price for a drug that
they're receiving for treatment and then
when they switch that cost can go up and
it's super easy to hear what Rachael is
saying and say well it's Obama's fault
these are systemic issues that are
inherent to the type of arrangement we
have in this country with regard to
health insurance I've been saying it all
week Hillary Clinton being the next
president will not solve this in any way
I want to be super clear about that but
it will at least allow us a 9th 10th
11th and 12th year of democratic
presidents to try to take the affordable
care act and expand it and move it
further to the left do ya do people also
completely just disregard the fact that
since Obamacare was enacted a lot more
people have health insurance of course
yeah that's ignored yeah you know
nobody's kind of talking okay we might
as well ignore it too because hey you
know if you either get it or you're
going to ignore it right I mean it
doesn't even know make it it really is
bewilder the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com okay I have an anecdote for
you that's really all it is but it's an
interesting one in a sense about the
failures of our health care system
although I know that this is both number
one relatively minor in the grand scheme
of things and that I'm fortunate enough
to be in a position not to be crippled
financially by what I'm about to tell
you and it's also not a serious health
issue okay so here's my medical
background on this particular story
years and years ago I was having knee
pain when I would run and when I would
bike and when I would play basketball
and my doctor said it seems like it's
more than just you know you're not 19
anymore you should go and see a
podiatrist and see what's going on could
be related to your feet so like 10 years
ago or something I went to a podiatrist
and the podiatrist said yep your knees
and ankles are not correctly aligned we
need to correct your arches with some
orthotic in soles she made me the
insoles obviously in the United States
the insoles themselves were not covered
by insurance so I bought the insoles and
paid my copay for the podiatrist and
I've had those insoles for a year and
over time for many years over time the
insole start to flatten out just from
the weight of the person wearing them
and I was starting to have knee pain
again so I wanted to go to a podiatrist
get a new evaluation find out if I need
new insoles and also have them look at
my feet i have something called greek
feet hilariously where the second toe is
longer than the big toe and it can
sometimes scrunch that second toe and
create some weird stuff on the front of
the foot and the nail so I wanted that
looked at as well okay so I made an
appointment with my podiatrist I did all
of the right things I have insurance the
insurance is a totally normal
middle-of-the-road what's called a
silver plan meaning that my specialist
co-pays are $40 this is with a big
insurer here in Massachusetts called
Tufts health plan I don't know if people
around the country know about Tufts
health plan it's a pretty big insurer
here so I do all the right things I call
my insurance
does my plan cover podiatry David yes it
does great which podiatrists does my
insurance cover
here's a list great do I need a referral
from my regular doctor to see a
podiatrist no you don't you just call
the podiatrist and make an appointment
fantastic
do I need pre authorization from you my
insurance in order to have the visit
covered no you don't David you just go
if it's someone on our list we will
cover all but the copay perfect I make
the appointment I go the doctor sees me
for 10 minutes ok 10 minutes says David
your arches are flat so you need new
insoles we don't make insoles here
here's a prescription for how the insole
should be made go to this other place
the insurance is not going to cover the
insoles the insoles are going to be
three hundred and seventy-five dollars
but your toes look fine nothing to worry
about there with your greek feet perfect
I take my prescription I pay my $40
copay and I'm on my way two weeks go by
and I get a bill for four hundred and
fourteen dollars from the podiatrist now
how could this be I paid my $40 copay I
didn't need pre-authorization I didn't
need a referral podiatrist covered I
went to a podiatrist covered by my plan
well it turns out that podiatry is
covered and I didn't need a referral and
I didn't need pre-authorization but the
diagnosis of flat feet is not covered
and that is how I was diagnosed and
therefore I owe four hundred and fifty
four dollars for the visit - the $40
copay or four hundred and fourteen
dollars so I say wait hold on a second I
went in for knee pain how should I know
in advance what the diagnosis is going
to be my insurance says that's simply
not our problem so anyway I was able to
speak to someone who said what you
should do is call the doctor and ask if
this is definitely wink-wink the right
diagnosis now of course someone at Tufts
health plan can't say David let me help
you commit insurance fraud call the
doctor and ask for a different diagnosis
so that we will cover him obviously they
can't do
but I'm reading between the lines and
they say this is the system we have I
would call the doctor's office and
explain the situation so I call the
doctor's office and I explain and they
say oh we're gonna get someone to talk
to the doctor
maybe the doctor can rebuild this some
other way maybe focusing on the Greek
feat part or some other diagnosis other
than flat feet so at this point again
fortunately this is more a curiosity for
me can i altom utley get this covered I
may well end up paying 375 for the
insoles for 14 for the visit plus my $40
copay right that's 829 dollars in
addition to my monthly insurance premium
of four hundred and twenty-five dollars
a month to get insoles okay
in other countries insoles are a hundred
bucks and the podiatrists themselves
makes them and it would be a fraction of
the cost so understand that part of the
inefficiency here is look at the number
of people that are involved with this
ten-minute specialist visit I spoke to
one insurance person before making the
visit appointment to figure out what is
and what isn't covered I spoke to
another insurance person after I saw the
doctor I was then checked out at the
office by someone in the billing
department to pay for my copay I then
called and spoke to someone in the
finance office for the podiatrist who
then will go back and speak to the
doctor and the care supervisor we're up
to seven six people being spoken to in
seven different interactions and they
may end up rebuilding this some other
way how much of the gap between the
hundred dollars this would have cost in
other countries up maybe 150 to the
hundred to the 829 that in total I'm
going to pay how much of that nearly
seven hundred dollar difference is
related to the fact that I spoke to six
different people about billing related
issues and again I'm lucky that this
isn't serious and that I can't afford it
if I end up having no choice but to pay
829 total for this ridiculous Fiasco
I'll be okay that's not the case for a
lot of people who can't afford an
unexpected $400 expense and then of
course there's the broader question of
why would it
ten minute visit to a podiatrist even be
priced at four hundred and fifty four
dollars which is again related to all of
the this BS that is part of the system
inefficiencies bureaucracy billing
coding non-payment from people who don't
have insurance and ultimately are just
going to skip out on the bill it is
truly a perverse system and I don't want
to make my story seem any more important
than it is I tell it merely as an
anecdote that I have send me your
thoughts if you have a similar story
please post it in the comments for the
YouTube video for this segment I do want
to hear from you about it
Kentucky Senator and ophthalmologist
Rand Paul is known as one of the more
kind of strictly libertarian members of
the US Senate and one of his I call it
one of his greatest hits in terms of
just saying whacky things was when he
said that single-payer health care is
effectively slavery that it makes
doctors slaves that it makes nurses
slaves everybody's a slave when you have
single-payer health care and we've now
learned he's going to be going to health
care slavery headquarters Canada for a
hernia operation you can't write this
stuff so I want to take this piece by
piece with you let me set it up first
here's Rand Paul with his now infamous
claim that single-payer health care is a
form of slavery
thank you very much with regard to the
idea of whether or not you have a right
to a health care you have to realize
what that implies it's not an
abstraction I'm a physician that means
you have a right to come to my house and
can script me it means you believe in
slavery it means that you're going to
enslave not only me but the janitor at
my hospital the person who cleans my
office the assistants who work in my
office the nurses if you have a right to
their services basically once you imply
a belief in a right to someone services
do you have a right to plumbing so there
it is everyone is a slave in a
single-payer health care system
according to Rand Paul if you have
single-payer health care everybody
involved in the system is condemned to a
lifetime of slavery and I'm assuming
that when he says that when he makes
that critique he believes slavery is bad
so that he wouldn't want to be
participating in such a sick system
except that Senator Rand Paul is now
opting to go to Canada for hernia
surgery remember that incident that took
place where Rand Paul was I guess raking
leaves on his front lawn and a neighbor
who I believe was an anesthesiologist
tackled him and Rand Paul ended up with
six broken ribs and a bruised lung and
apparently this hernia resulted from the
incident as well or from the recovery
from the incident so we have this market
system which I guess he believes is
great in the United States socialized
medicine is bad Canadians are being put
on horrible waiting lists for
non-emergency procedures but it turns
out that surely sore shoulders I'm not
exactly sure how it's pronounced hernia
Hospital in Ontario
is a really good place to have hernia
repair done and that's where Rand Paul
is going to go now I'm gonna anticipate
already what the defenders of Rand Paul
are going to say they will write in and
say David hold on I am opposed to the
socialized medicine system like Rand
Paul but this particular hospital that
Rand Paul is going to is a private
hospital not a public hospital that is
true by the letter but most of the money
of this clinic comes from the government
they accept the socialized health care
plan they're doing just fine no slaves
no problems one of the best places in
the world to have hernia repair done and
it's a perfectly reasonable model you
don't need to have the government be the
healthcare provider and the employer of
the doctors and the employer of the
nurses you still can have private
hospitals but you have one pair which is
the government which provides a system
of non-profit health insurance period
just because the provider is private as
is the case here understand that it's
mostly a publicly funded provider and
that's a model that's very popular in
the single-payer world and what we have
in the end is Rand Paul choosing because
of the quality of care at a mostly
publicly funded health clinic in health
care slavery a hub Canada he is taking
his tax payer salary out of the United
States and to a different country and I
was thinking Pat
the one hand there's this kind of
hypocrisy or double standard in another
sense this is sort of libertarianism as
intended by them he's rich and powerful
so he can go to Canada and get better
care other people can't even afford the
flight to Canada
never mind paying for the care as a non
citizen so they end up with the care
that happens to be available to them
with their terrible health insurance in
the part of the country where they
happen to live it's both an incredible
double standard but a version of
libertarianism that a lot of people like
Rand Paul actually support I really just
can't get over how dumb the argument is
that if you are for single-payer health
care you're forced slavery like doctors
are compensated a good deal of money
they make six-figure salaries they don't
have to be in that position if they
don't want to the free to go you can't
say the same thing about slaves and if
you're gonna make this slavery argument
when it comes to the universal health
care you have to make it when it comes
to any public official like Rand Paul as
a politician he's a slave to apparently
we will see what other follow-up there
is from Rand Paul here and it'll
probably just kind of fade away like
many of these stories do it's just our
elected officials being hypocritical
that that sadly is not actually new the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program Gerald Friedman professor of
economics at my undergraduate alma mater
of the University of Massachusetts Gerry
we've spoken before about your detailed
analyses of the costs and benefits to a
medicare-for-all or other single-payer
type healthcare system in the United
States we now have Bernie Sanders as
2017 Medicare for all proposal so what
better time than now to actually talk
about what such a system would cost now
you see the detractors of these systems
say big tax increase incredibly
expensive it's more promising a free
stuff that's not really free the counter
to that would be that it would save much
more money than it would cost so top
line how do we start thinking about
those numbers okay well the first thing
to do is to think about there are
actually three different numbers the
first number is what a medicare-for-all
system would do for the entire US
economy versus what we have now because
of course this there are big numbers
involved what we have now a big numbers
18 percent of our gross domestic product
18 cents of every dollar that we produce
in this country goes for health care now
a Medicare for All system would lower
that we would be able to get the same
health care for less money and this is a
point on which I think there is almost
no disagreement critics will admit that
yeah it would save money on the current
health care system it's almost
impossible to argue otherwise because
Medicare is a more efficient bill payer
than the current insurance systems
private health insurance Medicare
doesn't involve the type of marketing or
profits
that are involved in the current system
Medicare saves money for providers
because it's easier for providers to
build a single system than to build the
dozens of insurance companies and
hundreds of insurance plans in an
average american state to give you just
one quick easy example to show this in
Toronto General Hospital in Ontario
Canada with a single-payer system there
are two people who do billing in that
hospital Massachusetts General Hospital
is about the same size the same number
of beds more or less than other patients
there are 450 people who do building
there I mean so you don't save money
yeah now what about the there's an
argument that part of the savings would
be because if you have a single payer
they could force providers to just have
to charge less and thus it would
significantly depress wages within the
medical infrastructure for doctors and
nurses right how do you respond to that
now they would pay providers less
because providers would have lower costs
because of this Billings is saving on
the billing process and there are some
providers who currently are earning what
economists call rents which is a
situation where you have a monopoly and
you exploit everybody else the biggest
rents are in the pharmaceutical sector
you have this hepatitis C pill that
sells a course of treatments of course
eighty-five thousand dollars in the
United States it costs no joke two
hundred dollars in India so they are
exploiting the rest of us and the
research for that as for most drugs is
paid for in the first place by the
National Institutes of Health and the
National Science Foundation
so we already paid for this drug and
then we're paying again so in my
estimates
medicare-for-all you'd be saving large
sums on bargaining effectively for drugs
and there were also some elite hospitals
that would be facing cuts but not that
much Medicare currently pays hospitals
about 22 percent less than what
hospitals get from private insurance
companies that's overall now that is
about my esta it's a little more than
Mach but it's close to my estimate of
the administrative savings from
single-payer so yes the hospital some
hospitals like Mass General would
probably get a bit less because they are
currently exploiting the rest of us to
some extent there's abundant evidence on
this but overall hospitals would be wash
doctors would be wash doctors would
actually benefit those doctors who
currently treat Medicaid patients would
get a raise so overall we would achieve
savings of maybe six hundred billion
dollars or so on our total healthcare
spending and those savings would largely
come from being more efficient doing the
same stuff better so along those lines
along those lines there was an analysis
done of the proposal that Bernie Sanders
had during the campaign right so this is
not the most recent proposal book from
the wondering during his campaign and it
estimated that the cost to people who
are earning salaries wage earners would
be about a 2.2 percent surcharge which
is tomato Don someone earning $50,000
would be about twelve or thirteen
hundred dollars roughly can you talk a
little bit about in the analyses you've
run sort of what would be the costs to
different parties okay well then we get
to the second and third questions the
first question is the total economy the
second question is the federal
government and yes there would be a tax
increase that 2.2 percent was actually
what Bernie was proposing last year
plus some payroll tax there would be the
federal government would be spending
more and taxing more but that would be
replacing what we're already spending on
taxes that go to private bodies when we
buy health insurance it's mandated by
the government we have to buy health
insurance and we have to pay for health
insurance premiums to me and to the
Supreme Court that means it's a tax it's
just tax collected by private agencies
now the third question is for the
individuals which who would be paying
more who would be paying less because
well overall we'll be paying less in
public taxes to the government than in
private taxes to health insurance
companies because the whole system will
be more efficient but there'll also be
particular savings for some people
because in Bernie's proposal and in the
proposals that are written we have an
element of an income tax or a tax
related to how much money you have and
how much you can afford to pay where is
now your health insurance premium is
either a lump sum everybody pays the
same or sick people or people in
families with a sick family member pay
more so we put a tax on sickness um
which is a double tax in effect because
if you're sick well you have a family
member is sick your earning capacity
goes down because he's spending time
taking care of your family member or
that family member can't have a job
because they have a disability whatever
and then on top of that you have to pay
this extra health insurance because the
health insurance figures out that you're
sick and they put you they get you into
a plan that covers sick people I mean
you know they have to sell you insurance
and they can't charge you extra
pre-existing conditions but they work it
well that's it that relates to this idea
of everybody with pre-existing
conditions under Trump care versions one
two and three point oh all of which
which which so far failed would have
access to a plan regardless of
pre-existing conditions but that's very
different
it being affordable and it sounds like
that's sort of what you're getting at
yes what we already have is something in
that direction but there are limits on
it whereas what they would propose the
access that's just that's just I I would
use a word that you can't put on
television or your commercial in a radio
but you know access just means they have
to offer you a plan but they could offer
it at 80 thousand dollars one hundred
fifty thousand dollars you know and then
okay you have access you can buy it if
you could afford it so you and I have
been talking about a single-payer system
and are you experiencing that there are
people who are confused understandably
so not as a criticism between a
single-payer system whereas where the
government would be the one pair versus
nationalizing healthcare where the
government runs and operates the
hospitals and employs the doctors and
nurses do you see as much confusion
about that as I'm seeing oh yes
absolutely this and that confusion is
promoted by critics who say going to
have a government takeover of health
insurance no no yeah we're going to have
a government provision of health
insurance for people um if you want to
buy health insurance on your own this
isn't in Bernie's plan but it's in a lot
of the plans that I envision um then
yeah you could pay out the drugs why
somebody would do that I don't know
because they would already be getting it
to the government arm for free in effect
because they'd already be paying the
taxes but there would not be a
government takeover of the provision of
health care um Britain has that right
and arguably the health care system in
the United Kingdom is the best in the
world on government provision of health
care through the National Health Service
is extraordinarily efficient and
delivers very good care
ah but we're not talking about that
we're talking about something like
Canada where they have prior they have
private provision of health care doctors
work independently hospitals are run
independently but there
is government finance so all the bills
go to a government agency if you go to a
doctor in Canada arm billing amounts to
the following you swipe a card through
their machine the doctor or the nurse
types in the diagnostic code and the in
the treatment code and you're done
that's it the government agency will
send a check for your services to the
doctor the doctor deposits that cheque
in her private bank account all them
that's it Larry what is the best place
for people to be able to check out your
detailed proposals of how this would all
work financially and economically well
one place would be physicians for
national health plan P and H P org on my
2013 financing proposal is up there and
there's a wealth of good information
there top quality research on the
Canadian healthcare system forint health
care systems issues in the United States
health care system there are some some
of my work is up there and there's a lot
of work by other excellent scholars um
also another very good place for health
care in general is the Kaiser Family
Foundation kff dot org and finally the
Commonwealth Fund org
my most recent published work on
single-payer was from 2015 for New York
um and that is if you google New York
health plan I don't remember the website
mera naam yeah yeah awesome you can
always write to me absolutely yes and
people I'm sure will find how to do that
we've been speaking with UMass professor
of economics Gerald Friedman
always great to talk to you
oh absolutely thank you happening the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
hey David won't medicare-for-all kill
jobs this is a really loaded question
and I'm glad to have the opportunity to
talk about it there's this imagery of
killing jobs that is a very political
imagery to be quite honest with you
because the reality is that all the time
governments federal government state
governments departments of the
government whoever all the time
decisions are being made that have an
economic impact and they have an
employment impact sometimes we're
talking about thousands we're talking
about a thousand new jobs but we lose
200 but there's some economic gain or
some social gain from that change so
number one we've got to get away from
this imagery of quote killing jobs
because all the time as a country
evolves decisions are made that create
jobs and that eliminate jobs they cause
firings they cause layoffs they create
new industries etc what we have to
understand is that a lot of those jobs
that exist in the medical field right
now which would be unnecessary and thus
would disappear under a medicare-for-all
system are not jobs that are actually
providing for the greater good what I
mean by that is if you consider medical
ensure health insurance fraud
investigators medical billing and coding
experts on the insurance side medical
billing and coding experts on the
hospital side by the way not all of them
would go away under single-payer under
many single-payer systems they remained
all of this bureaucracy plus the profit
that is implicit in the system that
doesn't lead to better health outcomes
it doesn't lead to lower costs it's
simply yes providing work to the people
that are in those jobs and it is work
that is being paid for at the expense of
people who are buying availing
themselves of health care services so
would some of those things be eliminated
if Medicare for all were to be passed
yeah some of them would the economy
would have to adjust in history this has
happened many many times I give this
example often and I think
applies here think back to the
development of the automobile the
automobile was a much more efficient
means of transportation than horse and
buggy carriages or whatever you call
them there were people who said this is
going to eliminate the jobs of the
drivers I don't know what they were
called of the horse buggies would that
be a reasonable reason not or not to
allow cars to be developed or to prevent
the development of automobiles of course
not
ultimately those individuals no longer
were in demand in that role of horse
buggy drivers they were reintegrated
into the workplace in other ways some of
them probably suffered long-term
unemployment that's true but we need to
stop falling for this idea that any
policy that will result in any job loss
is unacceptable in fact it's actually a
very sort of center-right idea I mean
there's this infamous video of Milton
Friedman arguing with some college kid
where the college kid says shouldn't
there have been consequences for some
car company that had a car that was
dangerous and Milton Friedman said okay
well hold on so there was a negative
consequence from the car from some kind
of negligence how much should that car
company have paid to fix that problem if
the car costs 10 grand
and it cost them 10 grand to fix their
problem should they have been forced to
do it
what about should they have paid
$100,000 to fix a problem on a $10,000
car at a certain point you get to this
realization that there are going to be
negative consequences to doing the right
thing and whether you're on the Milton
Friedman side of that or not it doesn't
actually matter the point is every
single day decisions are being made
policy is being affected where some jobs
are lost there is some economic cost it
has to be accepted in a country of 340
million people anytime you make any kind
of change there will be people who gain
and people who lose right now the losers
are people who can't afford to pay for
care people who get substandard care
people who are going bankrupt because of
medical bills and those who gain are the
for-profit insurance companies the
elected official
that perpetuate the status quo in
exchange for donations and whatever else
yes some jobs won't be necessary under
Medicare for all the net benefit is
gigantic and that or some system like it
is still the right thing even though
there will be jobs that will no longer
be necessary and we just have to accept
that and not fall for the right wing
talking point that it will kill jobs and
by the way that is a that is an on to
the defensive talking point when the
right goes to Medicare for all will kill
jobs they've often already conceded some
of the benefits of just such a system in
terms of access to care and in reducing
cost that's why they retreat to it and
it is a very very weak counterpoint to
some kind of non profit system the likes
of which many countries have already
employed let me know what you think we
have a great bonus show for you today
become a member or a patron to get
instant access at WWJ in pakman.com or
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
let's go to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty
starting today with our caller from the
nine one seven area code whose calling
today from nine one seven hey David is
this man that is you indeed who is this
I'm Milo Milo what's going on just to be
up yeah so my question is about Medicare
for all so um a really common right-wing
and quite frankly you know a talking
point also from like a lot of centrist
Democrats is that you know Medicare for
all really only works in countries with
like smaller populations like when I
bring up that it works in like Sweden or
Norway or Finland or other Nordic
countries they say like oh well you know
those countries have like relatively
smaller populations but in a country
like America with like 320 million plus
people it can't work yeah so I'm just
wondering like how do you rebut that
point well first of all with ninety
percent of the people who say that you
just say why not
why would more people make it not work
and usually so that'll get rid of ninety
percent 90 percent won't have an answer
the other ten percent will have some
answer and then typically you know I
mean the the best thing is not to rebut
it with some
concocted talking point but just to tell
the truth which is the way that
insurance works the larger the risk pool
the more predictable the spending is
going to be per person and that actually
having more people in the risk pool
makes the system more financially viable
that you have way more people who are
paying into the system and that it will
actually make health care spending
significantly more predictable and that
there's there's simply no reason to say
that it only works in smaller countries
I mean is is mathematically untrue and
it's logically untrue right yeah and
also just like sort of one other quick
question I had one of and I think Kyle
kolinsky also brought up this point
recently which is that one sort of I
guess solution to that worry or you know
another way we could sort of do it and
America is you sort of federally
mandated each individual state
implemented like on the state level sure
so that population is no longer a worry
I've actually mentioned this before this
is a really good point
if you both if you want to make a states
rights sort of positive version of
Medicare for all
you actually have each state you could
argue that states for geographical
reasons or because some states have
these like cancer alley factories have
higher rates of certain conditions you
can actually say that different states
may actually need slightly different
financial characteristics and that each
state could implement their own
single-payer system partially subsidized
by the federal government through the
sort of taxation that Bernie Sanders for
example has proposed that's a fantastic
idea right all right well yeah my
question Tim all right appreciate the
call thank you very very important stuff
great to hear from
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]